de ma naissance à un mais six ans avant
l'âge des avant la naissance pardon de
mon petit frère de 16 ans tous passé on
va dire correct après pas totalement on
habitait dans une maison squattée de ma
naissance à un v6 en milieu des cafards
des ans c'est tout ce qui se passe dans
une maison squattée ensuite on on
déménage dans une nouvelle maison plus
grande au moins les les filles sont
séparées des garçons et voilà la venue
de manques du frère de 16 ans et à
partir de ce moment tout déraille tout
déraille et les violences commencent les
violences physiques les violences
verbales qu'est ce qui s'est passé qui
avez quoi comme violence 1 il y avait
des coups de poing et coups de pied
pourquoi pour rien
peut-être pour nous le cervia mais
peut-être pour eux c'est sûr que c'est
rien ça va être parce que on n'a pas eu
pays après la première remarque c'est
parce qu'on a pris un gâteau bout de
trois fois que nous obtenons un ca va
etre puisqu'on a refusé d'avoir fait le
ménage ça va être parce que on a refusé
de voir de vouloir aller faire les
courses à -5 dehors ou à 40 degrés l'été
ça va être voleur pour des raisons qu'on
commence dès coups de poing c'était des
coups de poing des coups de pied des
coups de bâton j'ai vu j'ai vu mon petit
frère de 16 ans fait rejeter un casque
de scooter de plein fouet par par mon
père
donc tu faire tomber par terre sa
respiration coupée devant les yeux de ma
mère j'ai vu des coups de balai des coup
de raclette j'ai reçu aussi ses couleurs
des coups de chaussures de sécurité en
fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient prendre
comme projectiles pour bien nous faire
mal il le faisait après il ya aussi une
maison que j'ai vu taper devant devant
les yeux les unes de mes parents un lui
lui mettre des coups de tête à plusieurs
reprises parce que tout simplement il
est homosexuel il est temps que votre
père à taper votre couple non non non
mon envie que la taper votre père votre
frère à vos silhouettes ou tout
simplement parce qu'il est homosexuel
mais j'ai vu mes parents nous malgré une
tête violent oui voilà plusieurs
reprises devant mes parents assis dans
le taye est en train en train de
regarder la scène j'ai dû une nouvelle
fois intervenir physiquement pour
arrêter mon oncle vous avez fait quoi
chez les messieurs réprimande avec des
coups mais si j'ai essayé de lui mettre
des coups de poing il m'a rendu les
couches j'avais 12 ans donc avec ma
force de 12 ans comparé à lui de ce
moment là il y avait 27 30 ans je
faisais pas le poids mais sur mon grand
frère non plus j'ai vu on sait qu'on
s'est fait aussi venir violemment un
c'était des trois quatre heures à genoux
à même le sol
on sorti plus nous ou si on avait eu le
malheur de tomber par terre c'était
reparti pour des coups de poing des
coups de pied des coups de bâton tout ce
qui était possible pour nous faire mal
mais surtout surtout ne pas laisser de
cool qui marche ne pas laisser de
cookies marqué et aujourd'hui ça sert
aujourd'hui sa soeur parce que grâce à
assat la justice a des doutes la justice
mais non cause toutes nos paroles
après nombreux témoignages de deux demi
frères de la soeur de ma mère qui a vu
certaines scènes insultes homophobes
insulte aux cours violence punition mais
pour eux comme comme n'y a pas de coup
marquant comme y'a pas de cicatrice
comme n'y a pas de vidéo je suis désolé
aujourd'hui auprès de la justice et j'ai
pas filmer man l'un de mes petits frères
ou l'une de mes petites soeurs en train
de se faire frapper je vais peut-être dû
à peut-être joué peut-être jouant tous
les coups les coûts pour qu'aujourd'hui
voit qu après tout c'est tout ce qu'on
dit c'est pas faux